Al final ha llegado.
Tras varios fracasos y unos cuantos escándalos,
2017 cerró con la primera gran victoria política
de Donald Trump y el Partido Republicano desde
las elecciones presidenciales que llevaron
al Despacho Oval al conocido magnate de los
casinos y la promoción inmobiliaria.
Hablamos, como no de la reforma fiscal, que
tras ser aprobada por el Congreso fue firmada por el presidente Trump el pasado 22 de diciembre de 2017.
Se trata amigos, seguro que lo habeis escuchado,
de la mayor reforma fiscal, en 30 años…
y, la verdad, podemos decir que tanto su repercusión
como la controversia generada han estado a
la altura de semejante acontecimiento político.
Para sus defensores la reforma fiscal supone
una auténtica revolución y muchos la califican
como la mayor rebaja de impuestos en la historia
de Estados Unidos.
Para sus detractores, en cambio, no es más
que una pequeña reforma, mal hecha y muy
alejada de las promesas que el presidente
hizo durante la campaña electoral.
Así
que creo, que las preguntas a responder están
muy claras:
¿Qué hay de verdad en todo esto? ¿Qué
supone realmente está reforma? ¿Es tan grande
como dicen? ¿Qué podemos esperar de ella?
Bien, veámoslo.
Vamos a ver en este vídeo los aspectos más
positivos y también los menos positivos de
una reforma que como primera consecuencia,
podemos decir que ha conseguido calmar las
aguas en el Partido Republicano; y en cierto
modo reconciliar a Donald Trump con los líderes
de este partido en las dos cámaras del Congreso. Y, ojo, porque tal como venían sucediéndose
las cosas...es algo así como una bonita historia
de reconciliación tras un año de pullas,
ataques y recelos. Fijaos en lo que se decía en los medios hace apenas unos meses:
Pero antes de ver que podemos esperar, lo
mejor y lo peor de esta reforma, veamos que
supone realmente una ley, que, creo, todos
tenemos muy claro que va a reducir los impuestos
en Estados Unidos.
Pues bien… la pregunta que tenemos que responder
en primer lugar es… ¿Cuanto reduce los
impuestos? ¿Realmente es la mayor bajada
de impuestos de la historia?
Donald Trump lo tiene claro, atentos:
“Hoy he tenido el honor de firmar la mayor
bajada de impuestos y reforma de la historia
de nuestro país”
Es decir, que según el Presidente, y también
muchos políticos del Partido Republicano
estamos ante una especie de gran revolución
fiscal.
Una revolución capaz de ridiculizar las bajadas
de impuestos del mismísimo Ronald Reagan.
Sin embargo, amigos, antes de lanzar las campanas
al vuelo, esperad un momento, porque, ya sabéis
que Donald no tiene un especial aprecio por
la verdad y ¿sabéis qué?
Esta ocasión… no es diferente.
Sí, habéis escuchado bien.
Esta reforma fiscal no es ni con mucho la
mayor de la historia de Estados Unidos.
De hecho, no está ni entre las cinco mayores.
(Veréis, aunque podemos decir que estamos
ante la mayor reforma del sistema tributario
en 30 años, porque esta ley amigos cambia
muchas cosas, lo cierto es que a la hora de
bajar impuestos… Bueno no es tan impresionante.
La estimación general es que esta reforma
bajará los impuestos entre el 0,7 y el 0,9%
del PIB durante los próximos diez años.
Esto es aproximadamente 1,5 billones de dólares.)
[Por cierto, un apunte importante, porque
es algo que siempre nos preguntáis en los
comentarios. Cuando hablamos de billones aquí,
en VisualPolitik en castellano, siempre nos
referimos a la terminología... castellana,
es decir a lo que equivale a trillones en
inglés]
Pues bien, el caso es que según el “Comité
para un Presupuesto Federal Responsable”,
un Think Tank independiente y no partidista,
y el propio Departamento del Tesoro de Estados Unidos
estamos, amigos, ante la octava mayor
reducción de impuestos desde 1918…
3 veces más pequeña que la de Reagan…
Atentos.
Sí, es posible empezar a pensar que lo que
le pasa a Donald Trump es que tiene, simplemente,
alergia a la verdad.
Pero bien ¿Cuáles son los principales puntos
de esta bajada de impuestos? ¿Cuáles son
sus beneficios? Vamos allá.
LAS LUCES DE LA REFORMA
Amigos, aunque son muchos los cambios, podemos
encontrar 2 cuestiones principales.
Por un lado la bajada del impuesto sobre la
renta, es decir el que afecta a lo que ganan
las personas físicas; y por otro los cambios
en el impuesto sobre los beneficios de las empresas.
Pues bien, en el primer caso podemos decir
que la reducción es muy, pero que muy pequeña
para casi todo el mundo. Atentos.
El 80% de los contribuyentes verán
incrementada su renta después de impuestos
en menos de un 2%... vamos que muchos ni se
van a dar cuenta.
Y el caso es que en esta cuestión Trump ha
incumplido descaradamente su palabra.
(Donald Trump prometió un nuevo impuesto,
mucho más simple con solo tres o cuatro tramos
y tipos mucho más bajos.
Al final la cosa se ha quedado prácticamente
como estaba, con siete tramos y tipos tan
solo ligeramente más reducidos que antes.
Y, ojo, porque eso no es todo. Además, esta
reducción es… temporal… sí, desaparecerá
en 2025 salvo que el Congreso cambie lo que
aprobó el pasado diciembre.)
[Eso sí, una cosa que me gusta de esta ley
es que limita las deducciones por impuesto
estatales y locales, es decir, para que nos
entendamos, castiga a los estados con impuestos
más altos y les incentiva a bajarlos]
Bien, por el otro lado, tenemos la bajada
del impuesto sobre los beneficios de las empresas,
que es por así decirlo la joya de la reforma:
Aquí, el impuesto se reduce del 35% al 21%
y además, cambia el ámbito de aplicación
de este impuesto que deja de ser mundial para
afectar casi exclusivamente a Estados Unidos.
Me explico, esto es importante:
hasta ahora cuando multinacionales como Apple
o Google ganaban dinero, por ejemplo, en Irlanda,
a pesar de haber pagado ya impuestos al gobierno irlandés tenían que volver a pagar impuestos en EEUU
por lo que habían ganado en Irlanda. Es decir, que pagaban dos veces.
Eso es algo que, por supuesto, las empresas
no estaban dispuestas a hacer, así que ¿Qué
pensáis que ocurría?
Pues que estas empresas, amigos, no repatriaban
los beneficios a Estados Unidos, los guardaban
en centros financieros como Luxemburgo,Irlanda
o Singapur por poner solo 3 ejemplos.
Y, ojo, porque las cifras son mareantes…
hablamos de más de 2,5 billones de dólares.
(Pues bien, ahora con esta reforma estas multinacionales practicamente solo pagarán al Tesoro
de Estados Unidos por los beneficios que obtengan en
este país.
Y para el dinero que está fuera… la nueva
ley contempla que puedan traerlo a casa en
condiciones bastante atractivas…
Así que,
es muy probable que este año empecemos a
ver una gran cantidad de dinero moviéndose
hacia Estados Unidos.)
Por cierto, un apunte, aunque la bajada sea
del 35% al 21% en realidad no será tan grande…
Por un lado, al mismo tiempo que baja el tipo
impositivo se eliminan o limitan algunas deducciones
que hacían que el tipo efectivo, el que de
media pagan las empresas, se situará entorno
al 22%..
Por otro lado aunque el antiguo impuesto sobre
beneficios era el más alto de la OCDE, si
tenemos en cuenta todos los impuestos que
pagan las empresas, no solo el impuesto sobre
Beneficios, lo cierto es que aunque en Estados
Unidos pagan muchos impuestos… por lo general
en Europa son aún más altos. Por ejemplo, en España, en Francia o incluso en Alemania.
Pero aun así, aunque no sea tan impresionante
como los republicanos cuentan, si que va a
ser algo bueno para la economía de Estados
Unidos.
Desde ahora el país sera más atractivo para
la inversión, sus empresas ganarán más
dinero y muchos beneficios que ahora se retenían
en el extranjero empezarán a llegar al país.
Así que... por todo esto, y por algún que
otro cambio más pequeño, por una vez y sin
que sirva como precedente, aquí en Visual
Politik, digo bien por Trump.
Pero… si pensáis que aquí termina todo…
esperad un momento porque estáis muy equivocados.
Esta reforma también tiene puntos negativos.
LAS SOMBRAS
Los que seguís habitualmente este canal,
ya sabeis que solemos decir que las cosas
no siempre tan bonitas como parecen.
Pues aquí ocurre precisamente eso.
Por un lado los efectos positivos de la ley
serán muy probablemente mucho más limitados
de lo que el Partido Republicano afirma.
¿Por qué? Me explico.
La economía de Estados Unidos está creciendo
a buen ritmo, hay casi pleno empleo y los
beneficios empresariales están en niveles
históricamente altos.
Es decir, ahora mismo las empresas estadounidenses
que ya son muy competitivas, lo que necesitan
es sobre todo menos regulaciones, poder comerciar
libremente y poder contratar a los trabajadores
que necesiten, entre ellos a los mejores talentos
que puedan traer del extranjero.
Y como sabeis...Trump… no va en esa dirección.
Así que sí, la reforma tendrá efectos positivos
pero no tantos como algunos piensan.
“Aunque no es el recorte de impuestos más
grande de la historia, es el recorte de impuestos
más grande peor diseñado [...] La economía
está cerca del pleno empleo y en cambio la
deuda nacional está en niveles récord y
creciendo rápidamente” Leonard Burman,
Co-founder of the Tax Policy Center
Por otro lado, este gobierno tampoco habla
de reducir el gasto público, todo lo contrario,
quiere aumentar el gasto en infraestructuras
y el gasto militar… y con menos impuestos
eso significa… más déficit y más deuda
pública… ¡Y menuda carrera lleva este país!
Y por último, amigos, la gran olvidada con
esta reforma es… la clase media. Tal cual
como lo escuchais. Los grandes beneficiados
por esta reforma serán sobre todo las clases
más pudientes… por supuesto, entre ellas,
el propio Donald Trump.
¿Se le habrá pasado por la cabeza a este
Presidente que él y sus empresas serán muy
beneficiados por esta reforma?... Ahí lo
dejo.
“El Partido Republicano ha traicionado a
las familias trabajadoras. Este engaño fiscal
se lleva miles de millones de la clase media
y se los entrega a los donantes de los republicanos
y a las corporaciones adineradas". Tom Pérez,
presidente del Comité Nacional Demócrata.
Tal vez, amigos, por todas estas cosas, es
por lo que las encuestas dicen que a la mayoría
de los estadounidenses en principio este cambio no les hace mucha gracia.
La percepción general parece que pasa porque
esta reforma se ha hecho por y para los más ricos
De hecho, contra lo que podríamos esperar,
muchos líderes del Partido Demócrata se
estén frotando las manos y piensan que esto
es algo que les va a favorecer en las elecciones
de mitad de mandato que se celebraran en noviembre.
El tiempo dirá.
Pero en fin, os doy mi opinión. A pesar de
que no es, ni mucho menos, la mayor reforma
fiscal de la historia de Estados Unidos, ni
tampoco la mejor, creo que sus resultados
van a ser más positivos que negativos.
Eso sí, insisto, Estados Unidos necesita
mucho más otras medidas que Trump ha descartado
y también creo que el Congreso de este país
debería empezar a tomarse mucho más
en serio el terrorífico crecimiento de la
deuda pública.
Y por cierto, un último apunte. Creo que
con esta reforma en cierto modo ganamos todos.
Veréis que Estados Unidos reduzca sus impuestos
es algo que limita que otros gobiernos - y
ahora estoy pensado sobre todo en Europa - tengan
la tentación de subirlos y subirlos.
De hecho eso es lo que nos dice la historia.
Pero ahora, turno para ti: ¿Estás a favor
de esta reforma fiscal?
Déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios y
también en esta encuesta.
Si te ha resultado interesante el vídeo dale
a like.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.